tre is with us in South Carolina hi tre
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up not much so uh let's
give you a little bit of background on
what's going on here about maybe seven
eight years ago I took FB you and I long
story short
basically ignored it doesn't listen
didn't do what I was supposed to do you
flunked oh yeah - sequester but what I
did remember everything that I did learn
in it I just never used it so about
three years ago I got married and bought
a house and your job a lot of changes in
my life the company I got a job with
they really pushed you know
self-improvement you had to read books
for the company and stuff and so I
started and listen to podcast radio
shows and stuff like that and I
remembered Dave Ramsey let me go back
and listen to that so I listened to you
pretty much every day my wife and I have
been trying to get on the same page with
budgets and getting out of debt and so
we've started doing your morning baby
step one almost out of it about to start
baby step two and we're I know that you
know you either have to lower debt to or
raise income one of the two so we have a
couple of cars one has about fifteen
thousand dollars owed on it and one is
paid for and we don't have a lot of
wiggle room in other areas so we're
considering possibly selling one or both
of them and I was just wondering what
your opinion was on you know doing that
to help knock out some of the debt
snowball
what is your household income uh right
at a hundred well a hundred and five
thousand mm-hmm okay all right and how
much debt other than the $15,000 car do
you have or your mortgage okay so we
have a $40,000 student loan and few
credit cards really everything
altogether probably just under 60,000
well that would be just a handful of
credit cards in right
like a thousand three thousand or two
thousand that's it yeah nothing made so
50k and you make 105 mm-hm
right and you have not stopped your 401
K yet and you have not started my new
Vinod started doing a written budget yet
yeah we just like literally yeah started
doing all this and you're still going
out to eat your until plan on a vacation
actually is that those about true yeah
so my wife has never done your programs
I'm the first she's heard of you
really and where is your getting ready
so your freaking cars what you're
discussing so the first thing is for we
before we sell our car we cut other
stuff in lifestyle temporarily and we
stopped the 401 K and we get on a
written game plan together and we say
alright let's not how fast can you knock
out $50,000 in debt making a hundred I
mean if you just use those two numbers a
hundred and versus fifty okay yeah that
tells me you can do this in eighteen
months but you're gonna be on beans and
rice and you're not gonna be running
around all over town like you've been
running around all over town and I would
rather rip the band-aid off and get this
done then have this thing where I screw
around with it for five years and I sell
my car so I can go on vacation that's
bass-ackwards dude right yeah okay so
here's the right here's the thing you
need to go back through Financial Peace
University with her and then you all
will start making all these decisions
correctly your car's not your problem
the fact that you're not completely
submitted and sold out to actually make
this crap behave and you kind of just
thought well we can sort of address this
is the problem the car is not the
problem ish is the problem we're doing
Dave ish budgeting ish
get out of debt ish and you got to go
like a whole hog like you care like
you're playing for the Superbowl you got
it you can leave it all on the field
and that's when you win at this stuff
and that's stopping the 401k the
restaurants and the vacations and
getting on a budget that both of you
agree to because both of you agree that
the best way you're gonna have a great
life five years from today have no house
no payments but a house payment what
would it be like to have no payments but
iostream it it's a good one and it's a
good question to ask her just say
breathe that in no payments but a house
payment we would have so much money you
know and then you can go on vacation go
out to eat right but right now you just
you're just a dog chasing its tail
financially and mathematically so hold
on I'm gonna give you a Financial Peace
University both of you go the nine week
class it's also includes a one-year
membership to financial peace which
gives you access to everything we're
doing every dollar plus the budgeting
tool connected to your bank it gives you
the follow-up class to financial peace
it gives you we've got a wonderful live
event coming up on money and marriage
event with less parrot and Rachel Cruise
on February 14th on Valentine's Day the
streaming of that is going to be
available to financial peace members
free all that stuff tons of stuff in
here I'm gonna give you the whole the
whole enchilada baby free the only thing
I require is that you actually go do it
and change your life this time and
someday when you're rich you find some
young couple the struggling and you pay
for them to go but for today it's my
gift to you
hold on Kelly I'll pick up we'll get you
going